[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه صالونها اليوم يتحدث عن ذكرى ليست
سعيده بكل الاحوال ولكنها ذكرى من الواجب
عدم اغفالها ونسيانها لان في تذكرها عبره
وبناء للوعي نحن في اواخر شهر مايو 2023
هذا يوافق مرور 20 عام على اندلاع اعمال
تنظيم القاعده الارهابي في السعوديه في
مايو 2003 مر علينا عشرين عام اللي ولد
يوم تنفيذ عن اول عمليه للقاعده في
السعوديه في مايو 2003 مجمع الحمراء شرق
الرياض وغيرها من المجمعات اليوم عمره 20
عام رجل يعني يعي ويدرك نحن نخاطب هذه
الشريحه ومن هو اكبر ومن هو اصغر ونخاطبه
الوعي بشكل عام اذ ان اغفال التاريخ هو
مدخل من مداخل اغتيال الوعي لاجل ذلك
استضيف اليوم على هذه الحلقه
على هذه الطاوله في هذه الحلقه الاستاذ
عبد الرحمن بن ابراهيم النفيريج كما
استضيف الاستاذ حمود الزيادي
الخبير الصحفي السعودي في قضايا الحركات
الاسلاميه والارهاب عبد الرحمن هذا الشاب
الجميل الذي ترونه امامكم هو ابن الشهيد
ابراهيم المفيرج من هو ابراهيم النفيريج
ابراهيم النفيريج مواطن سعودي صحفي رياضي
رجل خلوق كان محبوبا للناس بسبب خلقه
وتدينه الجميل هو استشهد في احدى عمليات
تنظيم القاعده التي استهدفت مبنى الامن
العام والطوارئ في حي الوشم في الرياض كان
ذلك في ابريل 2004 طبعا يعني بعد اندلاع
اعمال القاعده بعده اشهر معنا اليوم هذا
الشاب عبد الرحمن
وهو يستذكر هذه اللحظات ويستذكر اجواء
نريد فقط ان ندير حديثا حول هذا الامر حتى
لا ننسى حتى لا ننسى شعار مهم جدا مرحبا
بك عبد الرحمن يا اهلا وسهلا اكيد انك
تتذكر هذه اللحظات جيدا
صف لنا هذه اللحظات التي تلقيت في هذا
الخبر كم كان عمرك وقتها
وقتها عام 2004 كان عمري تقريبا 12 سنه
كان يوم زي اي يوم عادي طبيعي
الى ما صارت اللخبطه في في نهار هذاك
اليوم كان يوم الاربعاء
ويمكن ناس كتير ما تعرف ترى الوالد كان
مجاز في هذاك اليوم عجيب كانجاز
وراح لمبنى الوشم عشان يخلص شغله خدمه
لزميل له هناك
توجه للمبنى وحصل الانفجار في هذاك الوقت
وهذا اللي سبب لنا ربك في البيت انه
الاغلب يعرف ان الوالد مجاز ومجاز وكان
اخر مكالمه بيني وبين شقيقه عبد الرحمن
فريد العم ابو ناصر
عشان ياكد على حجزه لمكه
كان رايح مكه ياخذ عمر الوالد الوالد
وتوجه المبنى الامن العام في الوشم وحصل
الانفجار في وقتها احنا ما نعرف هل هو خرج
من المبنى ما راح هو مجاز
تلقينا الخبر على المغرب تقريبا بعد ما
طلعوا الضحايا من المبنى
وصاروا زملائه واخوانه في كل مكان يتجهون
في المستشفيات وفي كذا يتاكدون من من
وجوده
فوجدوه في احد ثلاجات المستشفيات وتعرف
عليه احد على المغرب صحيح
تلقينا الخبر الخبر للامانه كان
مفجع انه تفجير يعني ما كان شيء انا ما
اعرف هو تفجير سياره هو تفجير مبنى هو وش
الموضوع بالضبط
طبعا
يعني
العلاقه مع الوالد كانت يعني علاقه جدا
قويه حتى وانا صغير اللي فهمت انت تعبنا
الوحيد انا ابن الوحيد مع اخواتك مع
اخواتي فكانت علاقتي فيه جيده جدا ممتازه
يعني كان صديقي
فيعني في بدايه كان الموضوع
مستوعب ما ودي يستوعب
يعني خبر زي ده ما ودك تستوعبه ودك انك
تنام وتصحى ويطلع غلط ما هو صحيح
طبعا غير علاقته بوالدته
غير علاقته باصدقائه واخوانه بزوجته اللي
هي الوالده بنات كلنا كان الخبر بالنسبه
لنا الصاعقه
لكن الحمد لله على كل حال الحمد لله وهو
تضحياته لم تذهب سدى مثله مثل بقيه الذين
يعني جادوا بدمهم سواء من رجال الامن او
من الموظفين المدنيين الوالد بالنهايه
موظف مدني صحيح في هذا القطاع فضلا عن
كونه صاحب رياض يمكن الناس عرفته او عرفت
الصحافه رياضي اكثر من هذا الشيء ناهيك عن
الضحايا الابرياء يعني نفس التفجير على
فكره
حمود قتلت الطفله وجدان نفس التفجير اعتقد
في في الحي يعني سقط عليها نتيجه تفجير
سور منزلهم توفيت ايضا في في نفس الحادث
يعني استشهد العميد عبد الرحمن الصالح
محدد القيادات في اداره المرور
وكان وقتها
العقيده العميد فهد البشر كان مدير مرور
الرياض وقتها ايضا اصيب في الحادث واجريت
عمليات سريعه يعني يتعافى في خلال الايام
فبالتالي وهناك يعني في هذا الحادث سقط
اعتقد تسعه يعني قتله او سبعه قتله اصيب
العشرات يعني اكثر من مئه طبعا كانت تفجير
حتى وقت التفكير كان
يعني تم اختيار بعنايه من التنظيم
الارهابي كانت الساعه 2:00 ظهرا يعني في
الدروه الدروه في الخروج الموظفين الحركه
ايضا تكون في ذلك الوقت في المناطق
المحيطه تكون في يعني سواء الخارجين من
الاعمال او المدارس بالضبط بالتالي كان
التنظيم الارهابي مختار الوقت بعنايه وهي
سياره جي ام سي يعني مليئه بالمتفجرات
تم محاوله اقتحام البوابه
منعوا من الحرس
ركنها على بعد امتار ثم فجرها وبالتالي
كان هناك طبعا
واصلا يعني من من الاساسيات في الجهاد انك
تاخذ ولي الامر انت شلون قاعد تجاهد في
بلد يحكموا لامرك
فبديت تستوعب انه متاخر الموضوع هذا
وطبعا هذه يعني يمكن هنا نقدر احنا نقدم
رساله
للجيل الجاي الجيل الجديد
ابغى اتكلم يعني مع الناس اللي عمرهم
عشرين سنه وتحت بالذات انا ما بروح بعيد
2015 قريب ترى من ثمانيه سنين الي عمرها
20 سنه كان وقتها عمره 12 سنه صحيح
كيف يفجرون عند المساجد
فجر المساجد داعش كنا نصلي الجمعه وكان في
شرطه تحمينا عشان ندخل نصلي الجمعه
الحرم النبوي يقتحموه الحرموه
الموضوع ما خلص الموضوع ما خلص الموضوع
مستمر موضوع مستمر
وترى هذه يعني بعد لازم تفتح عينك و
نظريتك على الناس كلها تقرا الان وتشوف
كل الناس معهم جوالات وبالذات في تويتر
تقدر تتفرج الافكار مختلفه في تويتر
فتلقى مثال ناس يتكلمون عن
جزء من الناس اللي كانوا يسمون مشايخ
وانهم هذولي اعتقلوا بظلم وهكذا وهكذا
وهكذا من بعد يعني من بعد ما اعتقلي هذا
الروس هذول
الوضع الان ترى يعني الحمد لله على الامن
والامان فمعناه ان في علاقه فيهم
معناته في علاقه نعم لا احد يقول لي ما في
علاقه لا في علاقه لو ما في علاقه كانت
استمرت الامور على ما هي عليه لكن
يعني الموضوع واضح وصريح ولازم الواحد يعي
ويستوعب هذا الموضوع
في
حديث عن الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام يقول
فيه
هناك دعاه على ابواب جهنم لو اجابهم قذفوه
فيها
ابواب جهنم بالضبط عبد الرحمن انا عندي
سؤال مهم جدا مهم انا اسمع ويسمع حمود
ويسمعون المشاهدين كلهم
بسال هالحين بس بعطي فاصل عشان تفكر فيه
كويس انت واشرت النقطه مهمه تقولون في
اللي ولد هذا الوقت بيصير عمره 12 اللي هو
ايام العمليه الاولى دي عمليه 203
هل تشوف الشباب حتى اللي اصغر منك اللي في
عقد العشرينات حوله 25 23 24 سنه هذا سن
الحركه وسن
عندهم استيعاب للي صار قبل عشرين عام
واللي صار الى 2015 عارفين ايش اللي صار
ولا لا انتظر الجواب بعد فاصل وجيز فلا
تذهبوا بعيدا
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد في برنامجكم
الندوه نناقش اليوم او نتجاذب اطراف
الحديث حول
ذكرى مرور 20 عام على اندلاع اعمال
القاعده بشكل متتابع ولا في عمليات قبلها
حدثت في المملكه العربيه السعوديه طبعا
نتحدث عن اندلاع اعمال القاعده في
السعوديه انتم تتذكرون الفين مش الفين
حدثت عمليه تفجير مبنى في العليه اللي هي
مجموعه الشمراني والمعثم واخرين وحدثت
تفجير ابراج الخبر عام 96 بس هذه تبع
الحرس الثوري حزب الله الحجاز لكن الاعمال
القاعده تنظيم القاعده اللي وراء بعض صارت
خلاص هو اعلن التنظيم عن نفسه هي من 2000
مايو 2003 عن هذا الامر نتحدث
وشرفنا ويشرفنا وما زال في هذه الحلقه
السيد عبد الرحمن بن ابراهيم النفيريج
والده ابراهيم الفريج كان من الذين
استهدفهم تنظيم القاعده في تفجير مبنى
الوشم مبنى الامن العام في الوشم رغم انه
موظف مدني كان من الاسره الصحفيه السعوديه
وايضا معنا الاستاذ حمود الزيادي الخبير
السعودي والصحف السعودي المتخصص في مجال
الحركات الاسلاميه والارهاب كنت اسالك عبد
الرحمن قبل الفاصل الشباب اللي ممكن اصغر
من سنك الان في العشرينات وكذا هل
يستوعبون ما جرانا قبل الفاصل قلت اللي من
2015 لا اقصد من 2005 عارفين ايش اللي صار
هاك الوقت والله لو سمحت لي سؤال لان في
هالاطار
الاخ عبد الرحمن وقتها لما حددت الحادث
اعتقد كان وقت مدارس
اكيد انه رجع بعد ايام للمدرسه
كيف كان استيعاب زملائه في ذلك في تلك
الحقبه وكيف ردود افعالهم وكيف كانوا
يدورون الحوار خاصه انه عبد الرحمن فقد
يعني والده هل كان في ادراك ان هناك تنظيم
هناك ارهاب ايضا
البيئه التعليميه وقتها يعني في المدرسه
في المدرسه
وكيف كيف كيف تساءلوا كيف تناقشوا حوله
نقطه حلوه فعلا
والله للامانه
اغلب الجيل الحالي
اللي ما عاش قصه
هو وقتها وقت التفجيرات كان صغير في السن
فممكن يكون ما هو بمستوعب للدرجه المطلوبه
لكن بالنسبه لي انا واللي حولي احنا عشنا
قصه
فاضطرينا نستوعب اضطرينا نقرا
يعني مداركنا توسعت في الموضوع هذا
وبعدين في هذاك الوقت الناس يمكن حصل
التفجيره وهم صغار فاكبروا وينسون
بما انها توقفت التفجيرات لكن
صاحب الالم صاحب الالم ما يقدر ما ينسى
مستحيل ينسى وادراكه اكبر في الموضوع
وبالنسبه
للمدرسه اتوقع انه يعني في المدرسه عندي
كانوا مدركين لانه برضو كان عندهم في صله
مع شخص
والمدرسه في ذاك الوقت كانت تتكلم على
هالموضوع انه حصل تفجير وتوفى والد زميلكم
وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا وكذا فصار في
ادراك اكثر يمكن بالنسبه لهم
لكن عموما الجيل الحالي
يعني افكار متوسعه اكثر يقدر يدرك بسهوله
يقدر يتعلم سهوله
فالاغلب عارف وش الصح وش الغلط
الاغلبيه الجيل الحالي انا وحمود وربما
بعض المشاهدين من واقع جلساتك مثلا في
الجلسات مع الزملاء مع رحله كشته او في
العمل او كذا او في السوشيال ميديا حاسس
انهم مستوعبين وش اللي صار هذاك الوقت هذا
السؤال يعني انه تنظيم دولي وانه كان هدفه
كذا وانه رفع شعار اخرجوا المشركين من
جزيره العرب عشان يضرب العلاقه السعوديه
الامريكيه
لها ضلع في الموضوع ذا عرفت قصدي يعني
التفاصيل هذه في ناس لكن ما هو بكلهم
يعني انا زي ما قلت لك الناس اللي حولي
مدركه
لكن حسب انا قراءتي في فصاله في وسائل
التواصل وهكذا كثير ناس ما هي مدركه وين
الخلل
الخلل في التوجيه
الاعلام قصدك ولا في التربيه والتعليم
يمكن في الاعلام يمكن في الاعلام يعني انا
معليش لكن يعني واحد زي مثال واحد زي
سلمان العوده كان عنده برنامج
الملايين صح ولا لا
يشوفون الرجال في يوتيوب بشكل جميل
ويطلع وينظر عليهم طبيعي انهم يعيشون
تاريخهم ورجعوا وشوفوا تاريخ ما راح
يقولوا لنا كان غلط صار صح كله صح شلون
تقدر تقنعهم
كان في خلل في الاعلام وشلون واحد زي
سلمان العوده عنده برنامج موجه للشباب كان
وجنس فتره اعتقد ما زال مؤثر برنامج
اليوتيوب يعني حاليا لا حاليا لا لكن في
ناس تاثرت كثير مثلا باعتقال سلمان العوده
وغيره
وشلون شيخ زي هذا يعتقل
هو اعتقد عبد الرحمن يسير له نقطه مره جدا
مهمه انه هذه تعطيه مشروعيه وتعطي الخطاب
السابق حضور حتى بالوعي الباطن انه هذا
الشخص اذا لاحظ لاحظ نقطه مهمه جدا انا
اذكر في حجر الزاويه كتبت وقتها مقال وكان
هو يعلق على المقالات اللي تكتب عن
البرنامج وكان يتحدث عن التغيير
قيمه التغيير زمن التغيير سوى برنامج
بالضبط هو حجر الزاويه كانت بالضبط
فكان تساءلي انه يا سلمان العوده امامك
الضمير الاخلاق للصحوه
انقذه
هذا التغيير يحدث
كانت اجابته مسجله كانت اجابته انه الجميع
اخطا في تلك المرحله هذه ترى اجابه خطيره
جدا لانه حينما تعمم الخطا
يختفي هذا الخطاب
التحتي الذي يهيا لهذه التنظيمات وانا
اربط ايضا هذا الكلام ترى كله توثيق يوسف
العياري في مؤسسه تنظيم القاعده الذي
وقتها قتل يعني بعد بدايه العمليات تحدث
في رساله وهو هارب ولاحق ويوجه خطاب
لسلمان عوده يقول كيف تتخلون عنه انتم
الذين علمتمونا سمعنا اشرطتكم جالسناكم
حظر المحاضراتكم ثم تنقلبون الان علينا
عيسى العوشن وهو ايضا قائد اعلامي وشرعي
في التنظيم القاعده وقتل في
يوليو 2004
قال في رساله تابينيه مكتوبه ومنشوره ان
يوسف العياري قال له
حينما كان يوسف العياري اسامه بن لادن في
السودان حينما انتقلوا السودان او رجع هو
وقابل سلمان العوده قال حدثوا عن اسامه بن
لادن ونشاطه قال انني اتشرف ان اكون تحت
اداره اسامه بن لادن هذه نصوص ناشرينها
يعني وهذه المقولات تقالوها وتحدثوا فيها
بالتالي الرابط بين الخطاب الصحوي
والتنظيمات المتطرفه الارهابيه هو استمرار
لما بين الفكر وبير التنفيذ عبد الرحمن
اشار نقطه هامه قبل قليل انه لما تم
التعامل مع هذه القيادات الصحويه التي
تقول احنا مش قاعده سواء بالمحاكمه سواء
بعضهم هرب براس بعضهم الان التزم الصمت
بعضهم حول حتى يقدم نفسه باسلوب جديد نشوف
ناس حتى دخلوا في الكره على فكره يعني
الوضع في البلد معناته اللي تفضلت فيه عبد
الرحمن انه معناته في رابط سببي الشيء ان
المقدمه تؤدي الى النتائج صحيح يعني انه
هدا هدا الموضوع او على الاقل هو جزء من
الاسماء بالاضافه الى اجراءات اخرى وفي
يعني هذا هو الخطاب خطورته يعني انه احد
احد القيادات
المؤثره يعني قال بعد سنوات من التفجيرات
قريبه يعني وهو استاذ جامعي ايضا قال
تنظيم القاعده لم يعني لم يتورط في الدماء
كانه في كوكب اخر والتفتيرات حدثت في قلب
الرياض وفي المدن السعوديه
استدرك قال احضروا لي كتب
احسن الظن يا استاذ وهذه الخطوره هذه
الخطوره حينما يستمر هذا الخطاب او يبقى
تحت يعني السجاد ثم يخرج في لحظه ما بدون
ان يخرج واعي يفكك المنظومه الفكريه كيف
نشات وكيف تطورت حتى وصلت الى هذه المرحله
وهذا ما طلبت فيه حتى الذين حتى الذين
اعتذروا لم يفككوا الخطاب اعتذروا فقط
كلام انشائي يعني انت اعتقد تقول ان نحن
الذي فعلناه
الاعلام اتكلم الوعي الثقافي العام اخذ
اجلكم القمامه وادخلها تحت السجاد لكن لم
ينظف هذه السجاده
حتى لا تعود الميكروبات او
اثار السيئه لها تعرف الان ثقافه الفرجه
عبد الرحمن نتفليكس شاهد
امازون ديزني هل منصات الفرجه الحديثه هذه
غير طبعا اليوتيوب وكذا هل تعتقد لو واحد
الان مسلسلات ذات الشعبيه الاجنبيه او
العربيه
في شيء ممكن تنصح فيه انت شاب عمره 25
يتفرج عليه عشان يفهم المرحله ذيك ولا ما
فيها
والله
ما عاد الافلام الوثائقي خلها على جنب
يمكن يعني فيه فيلم اللي طالع في العربيه
كيف واجهت السعوديه القاعده ممكن يعني
للامانه انا انا ما شفت برنامج كان يتكلم
بالتفاصيل لا مسلسل لكن مسلسل الامانه ما
في ما في يعني لو تبي تنصح قصدي واحد تعرف
الشباب الحين ما يطيق يروح يقرا كتاب صح
بس ممكن تقول له والله عندي لك مسلسل مدري
ايش في احدى المنصات ذي ممكن نشوف حلقات
ممكن
صح صدق في شيء زي كذا
كان في حلقه تطلع مثال وحده انا اتذكر مره
مثله في طاش عن تفجير الوشم بالذات حلقه
واحده كانت خلال شهر كامل في رمضان فهذا
اللي قاعد اتكلم عنه ما قصروا بس هذا مشهد
يعني او لقطه من لنتكلم ملحمه يعني تتكلم
مسلسل خمسه سته اجزاء عرفت قصدي يعني او
فيلم طويل ساعتين ساعه ونص
انا انا بالنسبه لي ما قلت شفت من صاحب
شان يعني انت يعني
الوقت مثل ما قلت كنت توك يعني ما انت
مستوعب بس اللي صار يعني لدرجه انك تقول
انك انت تخيل انه حادث تفجير عادي ممكن
تفجير غاز ولا تفجير سياره عاديه ولا وين
الخلل يا حمود والله الخلل يعني متعدد
اولا هناك حاله كسل
عدم ايضا ربما جزء كبير عدم ادراك خطوره
ما عشناه
وان هذا كانه ناشئ صدفه وانقضى
رغم ان ما اشرنا له في الحلقه بعض الاماكن
انه هناك ارتباطات ما بين الفكر والجذر
وما بين هذه التحولات حتى ان حينما انتهت
القاعده خرج داعش وحينما جاء داعش ذهب الى
المساجد النقطه
الخطير يعني انت تتحدث عن حينما تعتقد ان
القاعده واسقطناها بالتاكيد على المستوى
الامني لكنها عادت بعد سنوات بوجه داعش
وهو اصلا
ابن للقاعده
مع عبد الرحمن في ناس تقول لك يا اخي ليش
تتكلمون في الماضي انتهى وراح بخيره وبشره
خلونا حنا ابناء اليوم ما لا داعي نعيد
الكلام في الماضي وفي ناس لا تقول لك لا
لازم نعيد الكلام فيه علشان ما يتكرر انت
معايير رايي لازم تعيدها عشان ما يتكرر
لازم الناس تشتهي لازم الناس تعرف ان
الوضع خطير انا قلت لك ترى عام 2015 ما هو
بعيد ما هو بعيد ابدا صار له ثمانيه سنين
من الان قبل ثمانيه سنين كانت المساجد
تفجر
قريب قريب جدا
وكثير ناس عاشت عاشت في هذا الوقت لكنها
بتكبر وما كانت تعيفه هذاك الوقت وما راح
تعرف لكن لازم يعرف لازم لازم يدرك
هالموضوع ولازم يدرك انه ما هو بكل شيء
يقال صحيح نعم
ويمكن البعض ايضا يقول يتفق مع الكلام
اللي تفضلت فيه عبد الرحمن بس يقول ممكن
نحتاج الى الاسلوب يكون جديد مختلف يتناسب
مع لغه الشباب ولغه العصر ما يكون نفس
الاسلوب القديم اللي ادى غرضه في وقت او
ادى جزء من غرضه في نهايه هذه الحلقه
نكرر الدعوه بالرحمه والغفران للوالد
ولجميع الابرياء الذين سقطوا في هذه
المعركه على يد هذا التنظيم اللي يوما بعد
يوم تتكشف لنا انه في ادوار خارجيه وداخل
قصه تونا في الفصل الاول منها يمكن في
الصفحه الاولى منها اشكرك ايضا عبد الرحمن
بن ابراهيم بن فريد ابن الشهيد ابراهيم
الفريج عندك اشكرك حمود الزيادي الصحفي
والزميل في المتخصص في مجال حركات
الاسلاميه والارهاب واشكركم ايها الساده
الكرام على كرم المتابعه نتذكر حتى لا
ننسى لاننا اذا نسينا سيعود الامر من جديد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]